doing a movie like this can you do it
without asking yourself the question of
would you do it I mean in the world of
this film if this movie was real life I
don't know if I would risk it right they
haven't quite exactly the science for
the most part I mean they have sure
ratio it's good you know it depends if
families do it and you know I don't
necessarily want to do it but I think
that I would like somebody who had done
it I think it would like to I should
make one of your friends that's what I'm
saying who would you like to have
miniature that you could carry with you
in the world who would you like to pal
around in your pocket maybe Emma Stone
yeah
she just seems like she'd be fun does it
have in your pocket a little tiny Emma
Stone
don't be mad at me please don't be mad I
can't leave my family I can't leave my
friends I'm sorry Paul I should have
been thinking more about myself thinking
about yourself 5ive you just saw
not often you get a chance to play
somebody who is less than likeable was
that fun it was fun
yeah I mean she does a really horrible
thing and I never get to play characters
like that it's kind of fun is that
something you you were looking forward
to because you are you know I would say
people like you but most characters are
very lovable that I do that where this
was just so far from that but it was
still very much a new character does
that make sense yeah I mean we tried to
to have the audience understand a little
bit why she does yeah terrible thing so
it wasn't just like you know she's a
horrible person
we tried to give her little things like
sprinkled throughout the beginning of
the movie that you're you didn't see it
coming but you weren't surprised when it
comes to you know doing these kinds of
movies where the you know you mix the
funny and you mix the serious and you
mix the everything else is that where
you are now when you say yes to project
to projects that you want a little bit
of everything in it no it's not really
that thought-out it's honestly it's like
I just read something or something comes
along I just feels right and my god and
I don't really think too much of like
now I want to do this kind of thing or
that kind of thing and I just kind of
depends on the project what makes you
laugh consistently I
tend to go for
silliness rather than and maybe just a
little more I like watching people that
are having fun when they're performing
you know like sometimes you can tell
when someone's maybe over over her sword
or something and then other people are
just like having fun she's like I love
watching like Zach Galifianakis
you don't put a cap in there
you can just tell he's having fun when
he's doing it you're all right okay
shot yourself a new butthole yeah went
straight down the cracks yeah feels like
it just grazed my biscuits right there
betwixt them Zach Galifianakis would be
another great guy to have right it's
working together one on either side I
look down
that's what I do
[Music]